orejas de burro
orejas
de burro
me cantaban mientras caminaba por el
patio de la escuela
y si mi maestra de primer grado me decía
tortuguita como no ser el centro de las
burlas de mis compañeras es que me
costaba memorizar las tablas de
multiplicar
no entendía los textos que leía mucho
menos podía evocar los
evidentemente para ellos esos eran
serios problemas
diagnosticada con una alumna con
trastornos del aprendizaje parecía no
tener solución y la escuela hizo conmigo
una suerte de promoción social le
dijeron a mis padres que me regalaban el
título
como no podía aprender
repetir no tenía sentido mi destino era
buscar una salida laboral corte y
confección cocina
para mi mamá
la palabra de las maestras era sagrada y
fui a aprender costura nomás para única
pollera que confección en mi vida le
salió más cara a mi mamá que mandarla a
hacer no sé por la mismísima el serrano
pero mi papá
mi papá siempre fue un rebelde y
entendió que no perdía nada mandándome
al secundario ahí los profesores
descubrieron el nombre de mi grave
patología
no sabía estudiar obvio
y también encontraron el remedio me
enseñaron a hacerlo así nació mi
vocación ser docente como ellos mirar y
escuchar a mis alumnos y dedicarme
especialmente a aquellos que fueran como
yo
porque yo quería enseñar a aprender
mientras me obsesionaba con mi
capacitación
la vida me mandó a catalina
mi hija
nació con parálisis cerebral severa
sordo-ceguera
hipertonía generalizada sus músculos
como contraídos
cuadripléjica postrada en una silla de
ruedas postural sin control de cabeza
con barbas ortopédicas en brazos y
piernas
corset coderas
se alimentaba por un botón gástrico y
respiraba por una traqueotomía
por momentos
era asistida con oxígeno
a pesar de este cuadro
decidí vivirla de otra manera y noté que
nadie la llamaba por el nombre ese que
tanto habíamos soñado con mi marido
agustín
sino por lo que era tratada
la línea de las caderas
del acervo cuna
a neurológica
su bien social era tan limitada
sólo era posible en las innumerables
salas de espera que visitábamos
comencé a preguntarme
a qué juegan los niños a esta edad
con quién
como aprende mi cata
y decidí buscar un jardín de infantes
común 6 común
cuestionada por los profesionales de la
salud que nos consideraron padres
negadores o locos
por buscar un jardín de infantes y no un
centro de rehabilitación
porque me preguntaron
porque no responde
la rebeldía está en mis genes
es que
una kinesióloga me dijo una vez para qué
querés que sostenga un sonajero
otra me dijo porque gastas tanto dinero
en ropa y no en más horas de terapia es
que yo estaba convencida que así mi hija
se sentía amada que me entendía cuando
la cambiaba buscaba conectarme con ella
desde otro lugar y que la gente le
pasará lo mismo que pudiera ver a la
nena
más allá de su discapacidad
finalmente un jardín nos eligió si
siempre digo que los padres que tenemos
un hijo con algún tipo de discapacidad
no elegimos las escuelas las escuelas no
se eligen
un día voy a buscar acá está el jardín
me recibe la directora y me dice no
sabes hoy cata sepelio con dos
compañeros pero después se amigaron
pensar que la loca era yo me dije ahora
la desquiciada de la directora
pero no
me cuenta que un compañero pasa
corriendo y le empuja sin querer ella se
pone furiosa hipertónica el amigo le
pide disculpa no ella seguía enojada
entonces vas a otro amigo y le dice
si querés que acá está se les pase
tocarle las manos así
así
a ese le gusta mucho
maravilloso no sólo la miraron sino que
también la tocaron el cuerpo les habla y
los chicos siempre saben entenderlo
aprendieron de ella
es que catalina era más que un cuerpo
que necesitaba rehabilitación era una
persona que necesitaba vivir y la
escuela fue más allá
me dio un lugar la nombró
la convirtió en algo más que una
paciente
a partir de ese momento
ese fue mi mo de la escuela una
institución que guía valora entiende y
atiende a todos y cada uno de esos niños
ahí los chicos son reconocidos
y alojados
catalina
falleció los viernes
gracias a la escuela se llevó con ella
un montón de experiencias más de las que
tuve yo a su edad
viajes fiestas salidas al cine al teatro
y como nada es casualidad
ella transformó mi mirada de la
educación y así comencé mi formación
específica en educación inclusiva
la gran oportunidad para poner en marcha
toda esta experiencia la tuve cuando
asumí la dirección de una escuela
secundaria común
y ahí decidí abrir las puertas realmente
a todos porque yo quería esa escuela la
escuela que vivencia de la que fui
testigo esa en la escuela que empecé a
construir porque es en la escuela donde
se puede cambiar la representación
social de la discapacidad
una escuela inclusiva es una escuela que
se preocupa y ocupa de todos y cada uno
de sus alumnos y al atender su
singularidad diseña estrategias
diversificadas o específicas de
intervención
el objetivo
me lo enseñó una alumna carolina con
mielomeningocele una patología
neurológica severa cuando me dijo
profe
yo no quiero dejar de aprender
entonces no debemos subestimar la
capacidad de aprendizaje de ninguno de
nuestros niños tuvimos si tenemos
alumnos con parálisis cerebral
mielomeningocele espina bífida e
hidrocefalia autismo asperger psicosis
retraso madurativo síndrome de dawn más
podría nombrar les muchos más
trabajamos con o sin maestras
integradoras de tiempo completo o
parcial con equipos internos o externos
que nos asesoran porque la presencia de
estos chicos en el aula es la garantía
para los alumnos en general de aprender
a valorar y reconocer la diversidad
humana así como aceptar y lidiar con sus
propias limitaciones
cómo lo hacemos
no hay recetas es una escuela de gestión
estatal con recursos limitados solo
puedo decir que lo hacemos con pasión
voluntad y formación creemos en lo que
hacemos de lo contrario no sería posible
cuando recibimos un alumno con algún
tipo de discapacidad lo primero que
hacemos es entrevistar a sus padres
nadie los conoce más que ellos después
lo entrevistamos a él aprendimos a
mirarlos a escucharlos no podemos
pensarlo sin conocerlos saber que siente
que piensa que busca y después con los
equipos externos psicólogos
psicomotricista psiquiatras terapistas
ocupacionales todos todos los que tengan
voluntad y capacidad de trabajo en
equipo tanto del sector privado como
público porque también articulamos con
escuelas de recuperación hospitales de
la zona organizaciones y fundaciones que
se acercan o nos reciben para ofrecer su
6-0 asesoramiento o capacitación
gratuita porque es verdad
no estamos preparados para ellos es
cierto por eso recurrimos a los
especialistas que se entrevistan con
todos nosotros para pensar las
actividades de aula o las adaptaciones
específicas según el caso también
trabajamos la integración en el grupo en
la clase y con toda la comunidad para
que todos se sientan contenidos porque
la inclusión social
sólo es posible en la inclusión escolar
como la diversidad es inherente a la
naturaleza humana estoy convencida que
todas las escuelas pueden y deben ser
inclusivas es más eliminemos el término
inclusivo hay un solo tipo de escuela
que se adapta a todos
recuerdo
estando en las filas esperando entrar al
cine con mi marido y mis hijos
un niño comienza a mirar la carta y
agita el brazo de su papá diciendo papá
papá mira
señalando a mi hija
una nena muerta
no era una pregunta incómoda a la que
estaba acostumbrada a escuchar era una
afirmación
el dolor
transformó mi cara como ahora mis ojos
se explotaban
pero qué culpa tenía ese nene
después reflexiones
por haber dicho cualquier cosa lo dijo
muerta
sí
y que están muertos para esta sociedad
nada ni nadie están preparados para
ellos ni nosotros sus padres
no les damos lugar porque hacerlo no se
enfrenta con una realidad que negamos y
a ellos con el sufrimiento de no ser
comprendidos ni aceptados
cuando recorro mi escuela
veo cómo se naturalizan sus presencias
para nuestros alumnos ellos no están
muertos
sobran voluntarios para ayudar a superar
las barreras de accesibilidad esos
mismos voluntarios en la calle no van a
ser indiferentes a las necesidades de
las personas porque aprendieron en la
escuela eso que se llama empatía
contempló el patio y veo se dará
carolina
del brazo de dos compañeros que la
ayudan a subir o bajar las escaleras
rápido un auxiliar y alcanza el andador
pasa muy rápido franco descontrolado en
su silla de ruedas y valentín camina
enamorado de todas enamorado de la vida
ezequiel agita sus brazos ensayando
acercamientos a este mundo adverso para
su estructura y tomás
tomás nos cuenta historias fantásticas
cada mañana y hasta podría ser escritor
podría nombrar a tantos a tantos se
juntan y conviven en un en un recreo tan
loco como el ideal la sociedad misma
pero mejor
desaparecen los fantasmas de mi infancia
no hay lugar para las orejas de burro
reconocer a cada uno como una persona
valorarla por lo que es estimular la en
sus aprendizajes animándonos a correr
las barreras de nuestras propias
expectativas
nuestras
una institución educativa que no da
respuesta ni espacio a estos chicos
una institución educativa que está
muerta
por lo menos para mí y la sociedad que
sueño y que es posible porque para que
una sociedad cambie el cambio se debe
iniciar en la escuela uno de los
primeros lugares de socialización del
hombre
entonces comencemos con lo que tenemos
si es posible lo hicimos nosotros que
tenemos lo mismo que cualquier escuela o
menos se puede
lo menos así me lo enseñó mi hija
y así me lo demuestran mis alumnos y
docentes cada día
[Aplausos]